Speaker 1: What is forthcoming in terms
of criminal charges for former President
Donald Trump. We are really getting into the
meat of this now as we see criminal referrals
from the January six House Committee, the Georgia
investigation, the tax returns, possibly exposing
tax fraud and evasion are coming out within days.
There is one opinion that is an interesting one,
which is from former Watergate prosecutor Nick
Ackerman, who expects Donald Trump to face both
state and federal charges. What would happen
if that took place? We will discuss. But first,
let's look at what Nick Ackerman had to say on CNN
yesterday. And his prediction predictions are very
clear and they sound confident. Now, remember,
many times people say things confidently and
they're wrong. So let's take that consideration.
Speaker 3: What do you think happens? That's what
everyone wants to know. Well, I charge Donald
Trump is going to be indicted. He's going to
be indicted in Georgia, and I think he's going
to be indicted by the feds. All right. I think
they've got the evidence. We don't know
exactly what a lot of these cooperating
witnesses are saying. And I think that you've
got someone like Mark Meadows, who's probably
the weak link. And if you're looking for the
one witness, the most likely to turn, I would
vote him the most likely to turn. And what if so.
Speaker 1: If this happened, what happens in the
United States? Because this would be a very, very,
very big deal. If a former president were to be
indicted, there would be a number of issues that
would have to be overcome. First and foremost,
who sits on the jury. And as I've said before,
if you had someone like Trump in front of a jury,
how do you find a jury that is not going to be
subject to appeal because of the preconceived
notions and biases of those jurors? There are very
few people in the United States who don't have a
strong opinion about Donald Trump, either for or
against. And if you find the people who genuinely
don't have an opinion, they are usually acutely
and painfully uninformed people that I would also
worry about having on a jury simply due to
their ability to understand what the hell is
going on if I'm able to speak candidly with you.
So I do think that the jury question is a major,
major question. But long before you even
got to that, it's important to understand
the framework around criminal charges for a
president of the United States. First, you have to
understand the legal immunity component. While the
president is president, there is significant legal
immunity from prosecution for certain actions that
are taken as part of their official duties. There
are disagreements among the legal community, if
not connected to their presidential duties. A
president while president went and committed some
kind of cold blooded murder. Are they subject to
prosecution? You can find legal opinions on
both sides of that question, but that's not
actually what we're talking about right now.
And that immunity extends to certain actions
taken after a president leaves office. But how
far that goes is also a subject of legal debate.
There are political considerations because the
prosecution and theoretically the conviction
of a former president on criminal charges is
undoubtedly going to be a politicized event.
And that can make it extraordinarily difficult for
prosecutors to actually get a conviction. And if
you do get one, you could have serious problems,
as I mentioned, in terms of who was on that jury
and the jury selection. And it's very finding
someone guilty in the court of public opinion is
a very different thing than finding legal guilt
beyond a reasonable beyond a reasonable doubt.
In a criminal court, you also have a burden of
proof issue when going after a former president.
You have that in general. But in order to get
a conviction on criminal charges, prosecutors
do need to establish the defendant's guilt beyond
that reasonable doubt. In general, that's a tough
standard in the American legal system. That's why
we have many acquittals. But when the defendant is
a former president with access to every resource
and advisers and the best lawyers, that can also
be a significant challenge to overcome. And also
these things move slowly. Trump has been out of
office now for just short of two years, and the
passage of time can make it more difficult to
secure convictions on criminal charges if there is
a lot of distance from when the alleged crime took
place. And this can be because of inability to
locate witnesses who remember relevant issues or
a loss of evidence or for a whole number of other
reasons. And also, it's important to consider that
public sentiment can change. George W Bush is a
good example of this, and I've been careful on
this probe. Graham never to rehabilitate George
W Bush's image while acknowledging like, okay,
he's not as whacked as Trump in a lot of different
ways. Right after George W Bush left office. If
you were to pull the American public, I think
you would have found that there was significant
support for going after Bush as a war criminal for
his actions related to the Iraq war. My belief is
and this is just speculation and maybe there's
polling on this, I don't know that if you pulled
the country now on that exact same question, you
would find much less support for going after Bush
for war crimes, even though the actions taken
a while he was president don't differ. Now this
is different than was he immune because these
were actions taken in Iraq related to his work.
It's not it's not even a legal question. It's
just a public opinion question. I believe that
although the facts haven't changed since George
W Bush left office, the interest from the public
in going after Bush for whatever wrongdoing he
may have participated in would have been greatly
diminished. And I do think that the longer that
this goes without charges against Trump, that is
potentially also going to be a factor. So Nick
Ackerman says legal criminal charges coming at
the state and federal level. We will probably soon
know as so many things are now happening at once